what would happen if you got nine hours
of sleep
for seven days in a row let's talk about
that so i've been doing a lot of videos
on sleep
um for quite some time and then it
dawned on me
i only get about six and a half hours of
sleep so i wanted to do an experiment
with myself
so i started to get nine hours of sleep
but first let's talk about what happens
when you get
not enough sleep poor sleep and i'm not
just talking about
not enough hours of sleep i'm talking
about the quality of sleep as well
well if you get poor sleep your immune
system is going to be affected
you're going to be more susceptible to
getting sick okay even infections
your risk for heart attacks and stroke
are going to go up
you're going to have altered blood
sugars where you're going to be more
hungry
and you're going to crave things because
when you don't get enough sleep
that spikes cortisol and that alters
your blood sugars
and if you're already a diabetic it's
going to make things worse
it's going to affect your cognitive
function in focus
concentration and memory
it's definitely going to affect your
mood you're going to feel more irritable
it can also increase your stress level
your tolerance
for certain people it's going to be
lower and
you're going to gain more weight because
most of the fat burning is at night
and growth hormone is mainly activated
at night
and growth hormone is the main fat
burning hormone all right so let me just
talk about what's happening with me
um with this nine hours of sleep and
it's quite
incredible i love it and i i'm gonna
continue this
because normally my neck is
very stiff i have a lot of arthritis in
my neck for mold
injuries now it's completely loosened up
i don't hear any more grinding i don't
have any more inflammation in my neck
i have more flexibility very interesting
the next thing i want to talk about is
my mood
it's definitely higher for sure i have
more
tolerance to stress i'm just more up
which is very another interesting point
the next point is i have way more
focus and more concentration when i
don't get enough sleep
and i'm doing these videos i'm doing a
lot more editing okay
now i do a lot less editing because i'm
just right there
right there i'm just sharper very
distinct difference in my
cognitive function next thing is i'm not
hungry
hardly at all i notice when i don't get
enough sleep
i'm more hungry during the day because
my blood sugars are affected
the next thing i want to mention is my
endurance with exercise
walking up a hill when i don't get
enough sleep
i definitely don't have the endurance
now i seem to have an
unlimited amount of endurance i don't
get tired
and the last point is i'm getting much
much better recovery from my workouts
so i just don't have that soreness i
bounce back
faster and i feel that there's just much
much better recovery going on in my body
now here's the thing for years i've been
getting up at like 4 or 4 30.
you know so i'd be getting about six
hours and i would usually take a nap
but at the very most i would get about
six and a half hours and of course for
years
i got so much more done than the average
person because
if you're up at 4 30 and you're doing
all this research and doing videos
that's a lot of extra time compared to
the average person
now that i'm sleeping longer i like the
way that i feel compared to the six and
a half hours
the problem is it's very difficult for
me to sleep past
six and a half hours so i've been
training my body
to get more sleep and i'm going to tell
you kind of what i've been doing
so first of all i'm in bed by 9 30 okay
i'll take my friendly bacteria probiotic
i'll take one capful of this
okay and just it helps me sleep okay
and i will take one magnesium
lactate okay this is standard process
you can use other
types of magnesium and i'll take three
of my sleep aid
okay that combination seems to really
help me because when i wasn't taking
those
i would wake up at two three maybe four
and i just had a hard time getting back
to bed so this combination
seems to be helping because now this
puts me out real fast
i'll wake up at 2 30 maybe 3 30 and then
i'll lay there for about 15 minutes
and i can go right back to bed now at
first what was happening
the first half of my sleep was pretty
good but the last 50
of my sleep i would have to kind of go
into
a rem sleep okay which is a superficial
sleep very similar to
uh feeling awake and then kind of pop
out of it and then later for a while
go back into a rem sleep for a little
bit pop back out
and then go back one more time so i was
going through this cycle of three times
waking up going back
waking up going back waking up so the
combination nutrition is helping to the
point where i just get up
once and i can go back to bed and i'm
finding the more i do this
the easier it is because i'm training my
body to stay in bed
until i actually achieve like nine hours
of sleep now the other thing that i
found is
i have to exercise one hour a day
because if i don't i have so much energy
my body is just not tired
so i have to physically do a lot to get
my body tired
so i'll do a combination of compound
resistant type exercise
and i will also do um some high
intensity interval training
mix in with that every single day so
anyway i wanted to share this whole
sleep thing
because i'm really digging this extra
sleep and i never really actually would
realize this until i actually went
through it
because now i have something to compare
it to and i feel much better with more
sleep
and so i'm going to stick with it hey
before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would
love to hear about your success story
please share it
in the link down below